歡迎收聽古埃,我是夢工
本期節目由立傑為贊助
立傑為是由專業營養師與研發團隊
透過嚴謹製程以及測試所開發的有效保健食品
有醫師跟營養師推薦的好口碑品牌
立傑為之前的維生素D有跟到嗎?
上次賣得太好,這次回來加碼福利推坑
小小一顆就可以補充一日所需的維生素
現代人生活忙碌壓力大
有些人小孩生出來之後就跟老了10歲一樣
那想要維持健康生活需要補充多樣營養素
這次立傑為直接給你綜合維生素
针对台湾国人营养状态开发
又分为男性跟女性两款
分别让你补充一日所需的营养
健康活力有效合护
力竭为的综合维生素
又添加美国专利AES酵素
内含四种营养酵素
能够增强营养补给
同时提供钙心酶猛
四项活性矿物质
酵素能够将营养素分解成小分子
更好消化吸收
那这样持续维他命才能大大发挥效果
力竭为有效男性综合维生素
加心定
内含13种维生素加8种矿物质
提供男性生理所需
再加上新有助于维持生殖机能
让你好活力健康满分
立即为有效女性综合维生素加铁定
含有13种维生素加9种矿物质
提供女性生理所需
再加上微胶囊铁
让你好气色美丽满分
还是知名江坤俊医师
唯一推荐健康更有效
那无论你是忙碌上班族
日夜颠倒者
想要健康生活都很适合来一罐
每日一定补充一日所需营养素
原價是兩罐1360元
那現在任選兩罐只要889元
優惠只有到10月11號
超低價福利
買給家人或是朋友都很適合
有興趣的朋友請擺握這次機會
你可以在連結單找到相關的購買連結
好那我最近看到他們喜劇圈在寫流成河
那我自己對於喜劇本身是沒有涉入
就是說我跟瓜吉 凱莉 博恩算認識吧
但是其實就是也沒有到很熟很熟這樣子
就是我們大家是可以講話的這樣
可是我自己本身第一個沒有買票進場過
然后第二个
平常也不会去看喜剧的东西
只是像之前杀太太就很客气
就邀我去两次
一次是郑博文演唱会
然后一次去他们的演唱
那演唱还超客气
把我排第一排
就让我坐在最前面看
那时候看是觉得还蛮耳目一新的
就是哇靠
这个形势竟然在台湾玩得起来
就台湾人就很轻
可是你竟然可以互相去抓
彼此的窗疤出来吐槽这件事
我觉得超疯的
然后里面我觉得最屌的就是熊熊
就是熊熊的吃屌事件
就是在网络上很红
其实讲白一点
他媽的到底有多少人不吃屌
男生吃屌女生也吃屌
大家要吃屌
只知道就是剛好很不幸運
他的東西被外流出來這樣
那本身比較像是一個類似醜聞的事情
可是在那個喜劇的包裝之下
被大家拿出來吐槽
雖然有時候為他感到有點不捨
可是好像就因為這樣走出來
然後大家也覺得他很有氣度很酷這樣
我覺得這個形式
看起來是互相傷害
但是某種程度上
好像也是幫大家解脫
就是把一個不好的事情
化成一個助力繼續往前走這樣
但我自己是覺得
其實任何一個喜劇演員
不管是国内国外的
还是什么电影里面的
还是脱口秀的
其实你要一直把自己很好笑的
一面呈现出来
就代表说你一定有硬住
把一些没那么好笑的
或是你真的想要讲的东西藏起来
就举例来说
他可能就不能像我这样
你赔钱的时候
今天这集听起来特别闷
明天那一集听起来特别有喜感什么的
你就想讲什么讲什么
那很幸运就是有一些听众
他就会支持你
你想讲什么就讲什么
喜剧演员就是
我就是要看到你好笑
你不好笑
我下场就不会去看你
应该说任何一个这种
比较目的导向式的工作
其实都会这样
就是你必须要一直把那一面呈现出来
其实这个过程是超累超辛苦的
然后在服务的过程之中
可能会受到一点职业伤害
就是怎么讲
你只要是在外面抛头露脸的
你在江湖走的一定会哀悼
就一定会有人讨厌你
不是每个人都可以像我这样
就是有我这样的思考方式
因为我的思考方式是
我根本不会想要花时间
去看任何一个我讨厌的人
我直接跳过你
因为跳过你对我来说最省时间
要把你关掉
我根本不想花时间去
什么按个导站啊
留个评论啊
这都是浪费我时间
因为他妈时间真的太短了
特别生了小孩之后就更有感觉
我时间真的太重要了
我有小孩之后
我根本没有办法打游戏了
那也不会因为这样
觉得后悔或什么的
就只是你知道
其实你想做的事情真的太多
想要去的国家太多
那想要达成的目标也太多了
那当然小孩就是一个目标嘛
你为了小孩
你就会牺牲掉一些时间
那你可能之后想要去环游世界
那你一定也会牺牲掉一点时间嘛
就是每个东西都一定有它的代价
可是你不会希望说
你牺牲掉一个时间
这个时间是没有办法
为你带来注意的
比方说跑去黑别人
跑去人家的讨论下面
然后参与吃瓜群众
开始去开干什么的
这个是没有意义的行为
就花很多时间
然后最后面就发现说
什么都没有得到
可能就是心理上觉得很过瘾
所以有时候我觉得
古代罗马竞技场在下还是存在的
就是形式不一样了
我们现在没有办法看到角斗士
跟野兽互相互干
政治太不正确
而且也有点残忍
可是实际上我们还是在参与着
各种网路上的竞技场
就是每次有事情出来的时候
大家就出去
微令
好像你的东西就一定
你的言论很重要
每个宣民就要去发表一下
他到底干你屁事
可能有些人就觉得
在发表过程之中他很爽
如果说你的快乐的来源
是来自于这里
那大家尊重
其实我看下来
我觉得
其实不快乐的人真的蛮多的
所以还是希望说
就如果说我的听众
也没有
不知道没有
但如果说
你是觉得自己的生活
是要建立在
看到血流撑河才会很快乐的
其实是不太好的事情
像我们这样偶尔吃瓜看一下
看到瓜吉要因火上升的时候
去抖内一下笑一下
就好了嘛
你没有必要说什么
真的就是很投入这样
我看到一些
有些粉砖可能想趁机去趁热度吧
就在下面就要发表一些评论
要去吐槽
要去让火烧的更旺什么的
反正就是一个很嗜血的社会
这是我看到的一个现象
那其实也没有什么特别的重点
就只要去分享说
我觉得这些喜剧演员
他们本身的工作是一个
带给大家欢笑的事情
可是同时呢
他们也牺牲了很多东西
其实哪一个工作不是这样
哪一个工作不是
牺牲自己的肝
然后换来我们的晶片
或者什么的
所以我觉得对于各行各业的人
都是给予尊重
社会上其实当然
年轻的时候会啦
年轻的时候也是比较那种
就是暴力之气嘛
在路上不爽就只要单挑嘛
或者说什么
你在网上看到什么东西
就像我之前跟大家讲的
媒体指谁打谁
今天议题在哪
就跑去下面会嘴个两句
以前会这样
但我不是那种很热衷的
那种什么网络报名
可是偶尔你看到的东西
你就想去做个评论
到后来就发现
自己越来越不评论了
当然也可能是你老了
你怎么样
你没有动力有什么的
可是我觉得其实就是
那个时间的问题
像我最近就还蛮有感慨
就想说
你知道大家这两年关在家里
因为疫情的关系
那你有想过说
这两年其实有很多人
他可能在疫情之前
已经做很多规划了
或是说
他已经在疫情前就知道说
他可以再活两年
就这两年而已
所以他想去环游世界或什么的
结果这两年就因为这个
一个意外的事情打掉
他本来就规划
然后他就挂了
就他也不一定死于什么肺炎
他就是跨掉
就自然死亡
所以很多你想要做的事情
我还是在那边跟大家讲
就是想要做什么就赶快去做
因为时间真的是不等人的
而且你真的不知道
什么样意外的事情发生之后
你会就是没有办法去做
本来很喜欢做的事情
像我本来一直都以为说
小孩子出来最好是不可以打电动
那不就是送去托婴或什么解决
其实没有那么单纯
你打电动时间真的就变得很少
所以我就很庆幸
以前真的是非常用力的在玩游戏
好像是把未来几年份的游戏
就趁下先玩掉这样
反正总之就是跟大家提醒
当你的生活有新的变化之后
很多是超乎你想象的
所以时间是真的非常宝贵的
好啦
那我们这一集来跟大家聊一下
走火入魔的事情
就是我在几集前有讲到这个事情
然后结果后来
我自己都忘记了
就蛮多人敲完
就很多东西我讲到
我们下次讲
然后最后我自己就忘记讲
所以大家来敲完的东西
我就把它优先拉出来讲
就到底什么叫做
进市场的走火入魔呢
其实我相信很多人
应该都有这个感受
就是你书架上
放满了一堆股票的书
然后你的订阅
然后信用卡里面
刷了好几个订阅
那同时呢
Wall Street Journal
你也把它订下去
Bloomberg你也把它订下去
我跟你讲
这两个报道最急巴的一点
就是你要退的时候
你找不到在哪里退
超麻烦的
就像他那种订阅报道
有些人贱
他把那个订阅的方式
设的超简单的
就是你随便都会订
可是你要退訂很麻煩
那有些還要你打電話過去什麼的
所以我覺得這還蠻惡劣的
反正總之就是
書架上都是書
訂閱訂滿滿的
然後可能也跟了很多的
這個所謂的投資意見領袖
還內外的
然後厲害的可能就是什麼
Dario啊
Horamox啊
那比較不高明的
可能就像台灣的國外啊
這樣子就陪你講幹話的
所以你可能就開始會追很多東西嘛
然後想說
啊我為什麼還是沒有辦法把股票做好
然後你就開始去思考一件事情
我的靠媽
股票不就是兩個方向
啊不就是做多跟做空
然后盘整我们先不算
因为盘整你也不会赔钱
除非你是用选择权这种
或是权整这种
有时间压力的东西
不然盘整你不会赔钱
那不就是两个方向吗
为什么我一直压错方向
不就50-50
那不就是五成的机会
我就是有机会赚钱
往上或往下
因为盘整我不会赔钱
那为什么我都会做错这样
所以你就会开始去
很深入去追究这件事情
当然呈现的结果就是
你订阅的东西越来越多
你买的书越来越多
那到底什么东西可以帮助你呢
其实我必须得说
就是以我自己现在的交友圈来说
我真的觉得各个方法都是有机会成功的
不管你是用这种所谓的基本面估值的方式
你是做产业分析
还是你是消息流
消息未必是内线
就只是你的消息比别人快
这也是一个你的优势
那或是呢
你可能是划线的
就是人家会笑的什么线线什么
干你没有看过真的超强的线线
他一样是划线
他跟那些什么一堆YouTuber在划线
都一样是划线
可是他超会赚钱的
然后YouTuber那些划线的都是赔钱
類似這樣
所以有些人他真的有辦法
在這個劃線之中賺到錢
他賺得到市場的潛序
那有些真的是非常高明的籌碼人士
這個在美股比較少
可是台股因為可以看到籌碼
所以大家可以知道說
哪些分點是誰
像之前比較扯
就人家跟我講說
某某分點是郭台銘
我都靠北
怎麼知道那是郭台銘
他就跟我講說
你看這幾個再看這幾個
這個就是郭台銘
因為他在買的時候
就是幾個分點會動或什麼的
就哇原來是這樣
可是也不代表說你追到
舉例來說你追到郭董的帳戶
他可能今天收股票就要
比方說他收紅海或是收紅純
或是收其他公司的股票
他就是放在那
然後就是一筆錢
他可能就是委託某個券商去幫他處理
那可能又有交代說
我要收的區間是怎麼樣
所以他也不會刻意去做家
可能就是擺在那邊低階這樣
那你說這些所謂的大戶籌碼
他今天進去買就一定會漲嗎
也未必
因為那時候看他的心態
他如果沒有要進攻
沒有要做價的話
他只是打算低階的話
其實股票也是不會進攻
然後他有某種程度來說他開始去吸納了一些流動性之後可能供需會失衡因為畢竟畢竟這個需求全部被他吃掉了那這個供給還是一樣這麼多所以可能今天假設有人進來輕輕的推一下
股價就漲了
都是有可能的
反正總之就是你會開始去研究
各式各樣的門派
然後我自己發現說
在我自己的交友圈裡面都有人做
而且他是可以所謂的長期穩定獲利
所以長期獲利不是像大家想像的
你知道很多人剛進市場想像的獲利是
我可以每個月從市場提款多少
那個是不可能的
真的是太困難了
当然有些什么当充天才
我们先不讲
可是大多数的人有可能是
三个月五个月不开张
但是一开张可以赚三个月五个月
这才是比较符合一般人的
投资报所谓呈现的一个状况
那我自己入门的时候
一开始走基本面分析
但是不是很纯的基本面分析
甚至是有一点烂的基本面分析
所以如果说你发现
你还在走这一套基本面分析的呢
那可能就是哪里做错了
简单讲的就是那时候我去找一些APP
然后是透过这些APP的帮忙
什么选股之类的
那我就希望說可以找到
現在呢他這個推算本益比是什麼
小於10啊
然後他的這個殖利率啊
是大於8%什麼的
就是我以前最早最早
我是在看這樣的東西
然後我會覺得說
如果我把越多的篩選條件放進去
本益比小於10
那本金比呢
小於多少
然後這個
目前的殖利率大於多少
然後以及帳上的自由現金流資證的什麼的
我就把一堆條件放進去
那你就會覺得心滿意足
因為本來哇一千隻標的
然後你放了第一個審核之後
可能剩下100隻
再放第二個剩下50隻
再放第三個剩下10隻
然後放滿6個你選好的指標之後
剩下兩隻
幹中了
就是這兩隻
這兩隻買下去
他媽all in我一定賺錢
就一開始一定會很天真會這樣想
然後你做一做
有時候真的很幸運你就賺錢
所以你就覺得
哇這個方法有效好高興
好像找到一個他媽自尊祕寶
然後跑去跟同學分享
超高興的我跟你講
那個投資很簡單
就是6個指標
6個指標key進去之後
他媽的那個股票
就是all in幹進去
就一定賺錢
然后就很高兴这样
然后你用久之后
你就发现说这个方法是失效的
然后你才开始去探讨说
为什么这方法会无效
就是如果说这个方法
可以持续把你赚到钱
那就是个好方法
即便可能听起来很白痴
但搞不好你知道
就是大家都忘了钻石
就在很明显的地方
这个默然回首
那人就在灯火阑珊处
你根本不用跑很远
其实就是日常的
什么券商的app打开来
基本的量化筛选进去
就可以赚到钱
如果说真的有这样
那我恭喜你
但是我经验是发现说
这个东西是无效的
就是說他沒有辦法為你提供顯著的勝率
所以當我今天可能壓贏了幾次
但是我可能下一次又把錢都賠回去了
所以你就開始去思考
說這個基本面分析是不是哪裡有問題
於是你開始就去理解
原來這股票是要看未來的
它不是看過去的
就是我今天不是去買一個什麼
公司過去的價值
我投資的公司
我是投資到未來可以賺進來的現金的總和
然後折現到現在該吃多少錢
可是你馬上要產生一個問題
好我知道要顧未來
可是我要怎麼樣顧未來
那一開始呢我也就是
零機移動很簡單嘛
2018年賺2塊
2020年可以賺到4塊
兩年成長了一倍
那2022年不就很簡單
不就是8塊嗎
就是兩倍兩倍兩倍這樣上去嗎
那當然沒有那麼低能啊
就是我可能會去看
這個公司呢
目前在七八九月
一月上一月成長是多少
那所以呢我就去推那9011月是怎麼樣
結果最後才發現說
還是有淡忘季之分
就算一家公司它真的是
按照你講的
它是稳定这样成长
可是有氮旺季
然后那股价当然也会跟着这个氮旺季会优秀改变
然后以前比较天真的时候就讲说
这个旺季来了代表股价就要涨
就后来发现不是
有时候是氮既先涨完
然后旺季又开始出货了
你就发现说这水之深
那你想要去了解这公司的未来成长性怎么样
当然你就开始发现说
其实券商报告是一个很好用的工具
然后你随着这个券商报告越看越多
你又开始发现说
原来其实有别家的是写的更好的
就这家写的乱七八糟什么的
那就去开了另外一家的券商报告
然后最后面
当你看了一大堆报告之后
你才发现说
原来这个在业界有个说法
我没有得罪任何人
我就只讲说
这个业界常听到一个说法
就是by side的报告是更值钱的
那你才开始理解说
原来外资有分
self side跟by side
self side就是可能我们今天看到的
这种
就是他会出示一个
什么目标价多少
然后告诉你说
这个公司展望怎么样
然后下修还是要上调
那个就是你看到的
卖方的报告
那还有一种东西叫做买方的报告
那买方报告就是普遍大家认为说
是可能会更强的
因为这些买方的研究人员
因为他们本身是有资金的
他们是要花钱去买股票
所以他们可能会做更深度的理解
可是你又发现说
这些买方报告没有那么容易拿到
因为你可能透过一些管道才拿到
但是你拿到呢
又发现他们也不一定是每次都看对
所以最后没有开始理解一件事情
就是说当你从本来最菜
你是用那个手机内建的
就是可能券商内建的一些基本的量化筛选
然后开始进阶道
你开始会有一些思考
你知道去看未来
你知道去推算本益比EPS
你开始从外资的报告看到
所谓的卖方的
然后再到买方的
然后买方的你也看完了
然后你还分析了海内外的报告
然后你发现说未必会赢
可是我们要解决问题
不就这么简单吗
不就是股价是一半的机会是涨
一半的机会是跌吗
可是为什么我们今天
已经了解到这种程度
还是没有办法赢了
你就会发现说那些可能
在写报告的人
或是所谓的buy side
就是买方的
他们是在超资金的
他们也未必可以在市场里面看对
而且有时候其实是
就是他们写的东西是对的
举例来说他写出来的这个营收是正确的
他写出来的获利是正确的
可是这方面股价并不是往他要的方向去走
所以当你想通这点之后
你可能就开始会进到下一个阶段
像我自己就是在这时候开始进入下一个阶段
那我的下一个阶段
就是去研究所谓的技术面的东西
因为我开始发现一件事情
我们拿最近的案例举例
像这个航运股
航运股跌到现在
然后在礼拜五直接跌停
三家都跌停
最大的三个货柜行业都跌停
然后我们才看到新闻告诉你讲说
CCFI跟SCFI
还有美西的运价大幅的下跌
就是可能几天就跌掉了几个月涨幅
那你就开始去思考一件事情
我们刚才讲这个CCFI跟SCFI
它是一个我们讲的基本面的分析的东西
可是为什么这基本面分析的东西会落后
就是股价的表现这么久
就是股价已经从高点下来早就腰斩了
可是为什么
就是等到现在我们才看到报价往下跌呢
然后其实像这个案例
在前阵子的面板
就是我跟大家提醒说
你要小心这个面板的报价已经拉平了
然后那时候面板一路跌
跌到现在可能到这几个礼拜
这个月你才开始看到说
人家告诉你说面板的价格大幅的下降
可是股价群创有达
早就已经他妈从3.3到3下了
那我也是因为看到很多这样的案例
所以我就开始去思考一件事情
就是如果说所有的讯息反应
都会呈现在股价里面
那我是不是我去了解股价的表现就好
而基本面不是那么重要
也就是说道理我都懂
我都知道说这个股价先行
股价会优先反应
所以那个报价可能是延后
因为总是有人比你先知道
总是有人消息比你好
那报价那也算是一个落后指标
那现在当然我们也可以很轻松的跟大家讲说
其实基本上你要去投资任何
因为报价而涨而跌的东西
你要看的并不是当期的报价
这个节目讲过很多次
你要看的是未来三个月报价
可是我怎么知道未来三个月报价
对啊这就是学问
如果你觉得未来三个月报价会继续涨
你现在就可以买
但是如果你觉得未来三个月报价会跌
那你现在就应该卖
这个我们在之前有跟大家聊到
就是你去追报价的东西
到时候你就得出这个结论
就是你不可能看到报价反转的
你才卖
那个时候已经太迟了
因为一定有人会比你先知道
那当然你误得这个道理之后呢
首先你会先试着很用力的去分析
我有办法知道三个月后的供需状况怎么样
那你可能开始去查一些另类数据
去看一下美国这边客户拉货状况怎么样
什么什么等等的
那可是到时候你就会开始去想
那有没有一个比较简单的方法
所以你可能就开始进入技术面的范畴
就是我去研究说
为什么那时候在高点的时候
就有人会先知道
他是怎么样知道的
这个其实有点技术面跟筹码面
只是我们先拿技术面先讲
就是他为什么会知道先下跌了
他知道之后他的动作是什么
他就是砍股票
那可能就造成股价往下跌
他就想他其实本来在前几个月
是你要买还不一定买得到
就东西一直在往上涨
就每次这个价格过了就没了
就很快就去往上推
可是為什麼突然過了某個時間點之後
變成大家願意一直便宜賣
這個東西其實在股票市場講
可能很多人鬼打牆會轉不過來
因為他心裡面就會覺得
我是在投資一家公司對吧
所以當公司變便宜了我為什麼不買
可是如果我們今天用貨物的角度去解釋
搞不好很多人就聽懂了
一樣跟麥當勞之前送的Hello Kitty全套
以前超級人送那種贈品的
這個全套可能在全盛時期我們舉例
就一套可能2萬塊台幣
然後最後開始變1萬5變1萬2變1萬
變8000變5000變3000變2000
這個你用鋼門響就知道說
這個東西現在已經沒有人要了
可是在股票市場我們會轉不出來
我們會覺得說沒有這個是變便宜了
這就是我們所謂的價值陷阱
就是你覺得這東西是變便宜
可是實際上是有人比你先知道
這個東西已經沒有人要了
所以他開始在出脫東西
那就此你就進入技術面的範疇
你就開始去研究說
好當今天摔破了前面那個支撐
你就想本來大家願意用這個價格區間在買
突然摔破了
那是不是就是有人先知道什麼
所以我就跟著買
就開始發現說
一開始去做這種形態的買賣
有時候被騙摔破的時候
隔天又拉回來繼續漲
拉回來你又追回來
隔天又再摔破
所以就發現
其實當我今天誤得了
這個所謂的支撐跟壓力之後
還是很多時候會當狗打
好像還是很困難
那你就開始想說
那我再往更進階一點
我去看一些比較帥氣的東西
這些數學公司推導出來的指標
所以很多人就開始去入門
這個所謂的技術指標
技術指標可能你用比較基礎的
就是大家告訴你什麼KDRSI
那RSI我已經跟大家講過N次了
就是他发明的是一个美国工程师
那他在之后出的一本书
基本上就是否决了自己的RSI
是可以预测市场这件事情
指标是没有办法预测市场
但现在还是很多人拿这样的东西去预测市场
或者有些人会告诉你说
KD就是20买80买
然后你就开始发现说
你80买了之后股价就一路喷
就是To the Moon
那你20买了之后股价就一路跌
那你才开始知道说
原来20买80买并不是圣杯
因为股价在这个指标顿化的时候呢
可能是表现最强的时候
也就是塔雷伯讲的那个观念Fatel
他可能才是最补最补的這個階段
但如果說你是堅持著20買80賣
那你可能就會錯過一大堆的行情
但當然一定會有人跟你宣稱說20買80買
沒關係我們就賺我們可以賺了就好
這個余生余偽給別人
其實到最後就會發現
這各個派別就是你信者很信反正你相信就好像我們這種就是一直想要去追求真相的雖然我直接講結論到現在都還沒有知道真相但是在過程之中你會試著去把每個方法都拿來套用然後你去試著去最後面幫他定義說
這個方法為什麼我不可以拿來當核心
因為沒有一個方法真的可以當核心
所以在這個KD跟RSI你都用了之後
然後發現的時候這個東西就還好之後
你會進展到一個比較厲害的東西
我覺得這個指標到現在我自己都有用
就叫做MACD
那MACD的MA就是moving average
那CD就是convergence and divergence
就是moving average的收敛跟发散
那这个东西其实它的本质上就是均线
一个长短均线去做一个变化
那均线之间的交叠的距离的变化
就是那种所谓的乖利值
用透过这个乖利值跟均线之间的变化
然后来告诉你说目前
这个你买的位置呢
是不是在乖利很大的位置
我觉得这个东西对交易上
先讲交易的部分
我觉得是很有很有帮助的
因为它会让你可能比较不会在
这个一个行情中去追高
因为你可能看到这个地方
是乖离很大了
那当然乖离很大
它有可能会更大
可能继续涨
可是你知道这个地方风险大了
所以你不愿意在这边追价
你可能会等到
下一次开始收敛回来的时候再买
所以当然这个东西就对你有所帮助
就是你开始减少一些追高的可能性
那我觉得MACD的指标确实是
就是相对前面刚刚讲的
这两个指标来说
它是好用很多的
那确实也蛮多自己的朋友
就会参考这个指标
我觉得MACD是一个可以参考的指标
可是當然你會發現說
就是如果你使用MACD
舉例來說我在零軸開始往上突破
然後在這個怪力很大的時候
拉回的時候賣出
然後你賣出很高興
因為之後真的稍微回調了一下
就之後繼續往上噴的
可是因為你的條件是在零軸之上
你才可以往上買
就是在零軸太遠的地方你是不買
所以因為這樣子你又錯過一個大波段
所以你就開始去理解說
其實每個指標都有它的局限性
其實剛剛前面講KDRSI
也不是說它們是完全沒有用
就只是它可能在一些狀況之下
它會讓你錯失掉東西
但当然他也可能会辅助你去做一些判断
所以你就开始不会去
所谓的文人相亲
然后指标相亲
有些指标有用
有些指标没用
就你知道他们可能
在胜率上的帮助
都没有办法让你变成什么
6成 7成 8成或是9成胜率
可他可以协助你判断
然后有时候其实我们就只是需要
一个参考基准点
就协助你判断
他未必是会大幅的增加你的胜率
可是他可以让你
至少把你的操作
锁定在一些固定的条件之下
也就是说你把变因变小
變因本來有好幾個
變因開始縮小限縮之後
當然你可能就更可以有效的去追求
說怎麼樣讓你的績效更好
當你各個指標都玩過一輪子
其實我們剛剛只是前面
隨便舉例三個
後來還玩很多
威廉指標震盪指標
超多的
Trading View上面指標全部開過
你就會開始去發現一件事情
指標的變化都是透過收盤架
收盤架以及時間軸來計算出來的
所以為什麼我不直接看K線就好
这就是很多人讲
所谓的裸K战法
就是我什么都不要看
我就只看价格跟量的变化
那其实进展到这边
我觉得就算是技术分析的一个进阶
就像那个估值的部分
如果说你还在算过去的
你就是菜基
你还在看那个券商给你的基本量化
可是你进展到你可以去算未来的
你就是变进阶了
那技术分析一样
就是当你还在依赖单一指标的时候
你可能是比较还不行的时候
但是你开始知道说
指标是可以灵活的变换
然后他们的核心
其实都是在一个收盘价
跟时间轴的变化之下
所做出来的
你开始去专注于
那我直接看这个
目前的价格跟目前的量能的话
你就开始进阶了
但是一样就是你到这个阶段
也不代表说你是稳定赚钱的
你今天看到价格突破了
你最近去可是有一大堆假突破
就以前阵子来说
如果说你是单纯做价格突破的
哇 动能流在前阵子赚翻的
就大家讲的疯狗流赚翻的
可是在这阵子
你去做这样的东西试试看看
你一定赔要脱裤
在这三个月这样做
你可能直接把前面赚的全部吐回去
所以你会发现说
就算我找到一个在某个市况可以做的方法
可是在这时候做可能也未必行得通
因为可能市况已经不一样了
那于是呢你就开始去想说
好既然这个买卖呢
就是会呈现在价格的变化
以及量能的变化
那不如我再往更上线去追
就是美国人做不到
但台湾人做得到
就我直接去追筹码
我直接去追说每个人的动机是什么
好那筹码这个东西呢
我觉得就是台股里面最悬的
它在美股你是没办法做
因为没有办法追踪到筹码
你可以看得到哪些ETF会买或什么
那就最基本的筹码
那在台股你可以进阶到
比方说我知道外资买什么
投信买什么
自营商买什么
自营商避险买什么
那自营商避险买什么
那比较像是比方说散户全镇做多
那自营商避险就要跟他做多
真的是一个
他会去对冲掉风险的一个做法
所以自营商避险
可能大家拿来当成是一个散户的指标
那自营商可能就是大家去看这些
就是有在自营的券商
他們可能是要跟牌
或是自己分析
然後他們選擇要買進賣出
這可能比較少人在看
大家最主要是著重於外資跟投信
比較進階的人可能又是著重於投信
因為外資的部分你會發現
有時候買有時候賣
有時候買到極限的時候
反而是要到貨了
所以外資的部分可能比較少人看一點
可能一些比較新手的會看
但是到比較進階
可能大多數人是追投信
因為投信他有一個作帳的壓力
他有績效的壓力
所以他可能進來他就是要拉抬股票
那他在拉抬股票的过程之中
当然大家就可能跟着
就是我们讲的
投信大哥一起吃肉
可是你发现
投信大哥你最近跟着他走的
你可能也是被棒打在头上
那比较基本的追筹码
就像刚才前面讲的
基本的技术面跟进阶的技术面
基本的基本面跟这个
进阶的基本面
那比较进阶的这个筹码面
就是我知道有些人会做到
比较夸张是他会去看
就是台湾的这些主动基金
那基金买什么
比方说什么
就不讲名字
就是比较有名的几个投信
那他们知道这个投信的绩效是好的
就是一定还是有投信
他是连年可以打赢大盘
非常厉害的
所以他们就去追
这些人买了什么
那当然最最最进阶
就是那种内线卡
就是前阵子新闻爆出来
什么劳退
那个有问题的
因为他们投信自己要买什么
他就开自己的账户
当然一定是用人头
可能什么老婆的
比较白痴或老婆的
一定是要用比较远的
然后他自己知道
他们自己的基金要买
他就先用那个账户买
然後去抬轎
這個就是把籌碼面用到一個極限
就會變成這樣
就是你在搞內線交易
那有些人就是比較合法的方法去做
那就是可能我去追說他買的東西是什麼
那我就跟著他一起買
那就是比較進階的籌碼派
但是比較初階就大家就看
今天投信買什麼
他也不會在意說買的投信是誰
比較進階就會在意說
那是哪一個投信買的
那當然又還有再更進階
就是甚至追到分點
哪一個分點在做什麼事情
比方說以台股比較有名的就是
比方說什麼嘉義啊
那胡偉啊
或是說什麼什麼
凱基台北凱基松山啊
這些就人家講什麼當沖分點嘛
隔日沖分點嘛
那他今天可能買了之後
隔天就把它倒回來
所以有些人就想說
那我就跟著他們做就好了
我就跟著買
我今天只要買
然後我發現
凱基台北跟這個
胡偉幫跟嘉義幫都有買
那太棒了
明天他們一定是拉高出貨
所以我明天
我不只在高點出貨
我還跟著放空
然後你可能做了幾次就發現說
這招真的可行
可是有時候呢
他們拉起來
如果他發現說
这个价格是好拉
他可能连续拉个两三根涨停
那如果你跟着是做空的话
你就被嘎了
所以你还是会发现
就是就算你追得到这种特定的分点
你还是未必可以去吃到他们的豆腐
因为他未必每次都会做一样的事情
好那我讲到这边
可能很多人觉得头昏了
就如果你不是专业的交易者的话
你听到这边可能就觉得干头晕晕的
就不知道他在讲什么
那如果专业交易者
我相信很多人应该就是信有欺欺言
就你可能也还在这过程之中
或是说你跟我一样
就是已经在这过程之中解放了
已经解脱了
然后你发现
就是去找一个真相是没有意义的
你不可能说买了一本巴菲特的书
然后照着他的方法做
你就变巴菲特
这是不可能的
你不可能去买一个Peter Lynch的书
那你就可以去接管一个基金
然后做的跟他的这个
麦哲伦基金一样好
这是不可能的
那或是说你去问到任何一个大使
他的方法告诉你
你就可以马上拿来采用
这也是不可能的
就是一些我知道蛮厉害的大使
就他们有所谓的找徒弟
就教徒弟一点东西
可是你会发现
最后面可能可以做的
就是其中一个徒弟
那为什么其他土地用同样的方法做不起来
要搞不好就心态不适合
或是他就没有办法误到
那其实真的没有一个绝对的真相
像我之前出一本书
跟大家讲一些
我觉得这个投资就像是灰烬思考一样
因为你没有办法在黑跟白之间
选一边站
因为真的太多东西是在过程中变化
更别提这个世界的变化太快了
就算我今天找到一个看似可以用的方法
可是世界一变方法就变了
这个动能交易在前阵子
你不用动能交易的你就是傻子
因为任何一个会涨的股票
你追进去你就是赚钱
可是在这阵子
如果你做动人交易的
你就是赔到脱库嘛
所以试况变了
那你可能方法也要跟着再改变
所以其实就是工具箱里面
准备越多的东西
那他可能就可以为你带来越多的帮助
所以你到后来你就不会去
什么歧视其他人的估值方法
歧视其他人技术指标怎么用
歧视其他人的筹码怎么样追
你会发现那就是
就算真的有一个人很强好了
可是他也未必可以在每个试况之中
都用他的方法可以持续的去获利
比方来说像去年
在疫情赚很多钱的那一位
就是Pershyn Square的老板
那Bill Ackman
Bill Ackman在之前的有一段时间
绩效之烂
烂到就是他一大堆投资人都撤了
结果他突然就是一个sexy back
超厉害的转身
然后做了一个号称是
可能可以跟大麦空的Michael Burry比的
一个超经典的交易
那就因为这样就把绩效整个冲到天上去
就是他在过去那种很鸟石的时期
那你说他的方法是真的很烂很废吗
那他如果没有撑到后面
可能就这样就概观论定了吧
可是他过了2020年之后
大家就发现说
他其实是一个天才之类的
所以其实
就是大家不要在这过程之中
过度的去把自己锁死在
就是我好像一定要跟一个学派
然后我一定要做怎么样的方法
因为你到最后发现说
这个市场的变化太快了
所以你能做的就只是
然后你可能饱读师书
学义都有的没有
甚至其实你根本不用学这么多东西
就让自己尽量单纯一点
然后你只要想办法去找到一个
这个方法是我坐下来
我是舒服
我是可以坐的
就像是吃饭一样
就是好吃的菜你才会继续吃吧
不会有人神经病这个东西不好吃
我一定要塞吧
那你为了健康那是例外
那就一样的道理
就如果这个投资方法我做的是顺的
那其实你不用太在意说
一定要爆赚赚多块什么
反正是顺的我的财富有在成长
而且我做得很快乐
那其实就这样去做下去
就没有问题了
好那大概是这样子希望大家都可以度过自己走后入魔的时间我是走后入魔蛮久的因為我那時候是真的一直很想要找一個先單一個解方然後到最後發現說沒有解方其實就是無限種的排列組合
然後每次出了不一樣的菜
你就用不一樣的方法去解它
那就算你用不一樣的方法去解它
你覺得自己很聰明
可是有時候用這個方法去解
未必是對的
所以到最後都是不停的try and narrow
大概是這樣
好那我們進入QA的部分
第一位say please
他說拿老婆的iPhone來催你
那乖大鳥
我平時上班都是在車上度過
我听你的podcast
已经一年多
挂号三刷
那目前还是在观望
没进苦时
但借人的投资心法
那我在其他的投资上
挂号求援卡
也是有很大的受益
不管是在行为
还是在心态上
真心建议
有在做任何投资的人
都应该要听一轮
那我用我的真心
帮你吹吹吹到色
那最后小弟有个
应该会被你说
是被狗干到的要求
那我一直都很爱
你学酸民的
酸民那个七八的语气
那每一集都在
期盼这个声音
希望你可以用这个声音说
我欢迎收听鼓啊
我是西洋公团本期
只有求我该你的赞助
谢谢阿姨哥哥
我觉得我最近开始
越来越容易
被我的听众给操弄了
下面会有这个Jason HKC
他说一直没被念叨
一直挑战
那五星吹吹号报
艾达你好
先感谢艾达一直
来的分享投资观念
让小弟从赔道内裤脱光
进步到内裤穿一半回来
那想请教一下
艾达说外汇交易
那小弟有朋友在玩
听说波动超大
朋友每天都有很多表情包
早上笑得跟中邪一样
下午就脸绿的
但外汇玩的应该就是汇率价差
如果不是本金超级大
那个价差应该也很小
听说有一种叫做差价合约
CFD的方法可以玩外汇
那上网查一下
CFD感觉跟期货有点类似
还请挨大开示一下
为何没钱到被绿的小资组朋友
可以每天玩外汇
玩到跟奇迹一样
那谢谢挨大
祝全家平安股票天天涨翻天
天天开心
好非常谢谢
那你讲的这个差价合约CFD
就是contract for difference
就是說你跟這個發行商對賭
簡單來講就是場外賭場的意思
有點像是場內賭場
就是我們舉例來說
NYSE New York Stock Exchange
或是說NASDAQ
就是美國的交易所
那場外賭場呢
就是我今天開一個網站
我直接跟你賭說這個點數
比方說今天是Apple是100點
100塊嘛
那你進去交易所交易那是一回事
但我可以在外面跟你賭
就是100塊那漲到120
那我就要付你20塊嘛
那如果說跌到80
那你的這個保證你會被我吃掉嘛
這就是CFD的概念
但是CFD它有一個特色就是說
它可以把槓桿開到很大
因為你就是在跟它對賭
那當然它一定會做避險
它的就是對賭方
莊家它自己要怎麼變化
那它的事情
但CFD的核心就是
你們在場外開一個賭場
然後在對賭場內的東西
簡單來說就是這樣子
那在玩外匯的
因為外匯的變動是很小的
它不像可能最大就加密貨幣
一天80%
幹嚇死人了
那心臟小的
我都很建議去加密貨幣
就入金一點點錢
你去训练你的心脏
不然股票跌个3%哇哇叫
加密货币一天2 30%在发生的
你可能心脏就变很大
这是很大的
股票市场可能也是一天有个
夸张一点5% 8%可以看到
债券市场可能就是在相对更小
外汇市场也是属于很小很小
就是汇率不太会
除非你今天是一些很极端的国家
一天发生战争汇率极扁之类的
不然其实外汇的变化都很小
你说为什么它可以赌得很大
因为所有的外汇交易
他们也是在做
所谓的外汇保证金交易
也就是它是透过大量的杠杆
具体来说有些外汇
我知道可以开比较夸张
是百倍两百倍之类的
那比较基本款
可能也是50倍100倍来开
也就是说因为它的变化很小
所以你就用更大的杠杆去撬动它
所以它可能
就算你的本金没有到很大
然后你可能看这个外汇波动
没有到很大
可是你透过大量的杠杆
你还是可以做出
就是你一天让你的损益
达到就是非常高的
百分比的一个做法
那建不建议大家玩呢
其实我一直都跟大家讲说
我觉得是这样
就是股票市场是一个
你相对可以去预测未来的
就是亚马逊东西好不好
苹果东西好不好
特斯拉好不好
至少你可以开到车子
你可以拆到未来
但是我觉得外汇它比较困难
是因为它其实是
第一个国家之间的变化
没有那么容易去预测
然后第二个是
这是一个世界央行的战场
央行跟我们一般人类比起来
它是就像之前很早期的节目讲
他们就像是克苏鲁
我们就像是人类
克苏鲁对人类是没有情感的
它可以轻松就把它撵过去
因为对它来说
像这个美国在2020年3月
它释出那个流动性
直接就把股市他妈硬拉回来
就是马上就解决一大堆问题
所以当这个央行之间在对战的时候
我们凡人在里面要吃到肉
我觉得是相对困难的
所以我觉得外汇交易
跟这种所谓的债券交易
其实很多时候都是
我们讲就那种可能真正的天才
很厉害的人在做的
那我背
像我自己有觉得我做不来
我真的是至少以我看下来
我觉得你要去在这里面赚钱
那个几率是更小的
就是比你可能在股票里面
做投资要赚钱的机会是来的更小的
这是我的想法
下面这个King Ning
他说股外有限公司
那谢董事长你好
五星奉上
很常QA听到大家询问
投资值利率高并配发股利的标的
而不是指数型ETF
那想请问投资大盘的资本利得如何再投入
现金股利是左手发右手
但本金不动的状况之下
投进去0050或是006208
大盘指数型ETF
要怎么在本金不增加的状况之下再投入
那基本上还是要有策略获利了结
然后再找低点承接吗
那实务上如果说买金融股固定配现金股利
以赵丰金为例30块配1块钱
那百万本金每年就会多配3万
可以买一张可以持续再投入
那很多报道也是以每年零百万现金股利做标题
那投资指数型ETF虽然也有现金股利
但是股价越来越高无法再投入
那操作必须要搭配看盘
低买高卖才可以再实现再投入
那赵峰金本金下去之后
鼓励配完就再投入无脑买
那退休之后呢
看本金复利加总多少
每年现金鼓励拆分当做每月花费
而ETF为什么会被认为是纸上富贵
大概是因为每年的资本利得
都看起来越来越高
但卖掉不知道能不能买回来
假设0050去年买在100块
那目前价格落在130上下
一张就赚3万块
那买赵峰金要90万才配得到3万
0050一张10万
现在13万卖掉就可以获利3万
差别在于没有本金继续投
只能看他慢慢的继续上去
放了几年也有可能报过一座山
Thank you K
好啦那你这题又是万年老梗
我发现很多人真的过不去这一关
以后要来问这问题前
先请你们做一件事情
就是你把还原全息之后的报酬
这网络上都找得到
你抓了一个年份
然后到现在
然后去比另外一个还原全息之后的报酬
因为这个假设就是说
假设他没有把息配出来给你
那实际上资本利的报酬是多少吗
那更别提0050他不是没有配息
0050也是有在配息的
趙鋒金的殖利率我記得好像是大概落在6%
那0050的殖利率好像是落在4%
那可是0050的資本利得應該是屌打趙鋒金
那我這邊直接幫你拉看看我們就知道了
我手邊有軟體我們直接看
就是我們用0050然後去VS
趙鋒金是2886
2886 OK一筆
然後在這邊
2015年到2021
快2022了
哇靠媽的今年要過了
我們直接來最左邊是2015年
那0050的報酬從2015年到現在是100%
就是一倍
這個是不含就是我把股息再投入的部分
那兆風金的部分呢是31.08%
那一樣是不含股息再投入的部分
所以基本上是贏了三倍
那你說0050會不會有報過一座山
有可能啊
就是台灣假設整個衰落下去的話
但是你覺得台灣衰落下去
我們金融股活下去嗎
就是這是一個大災問啊
那再三強調有沒有要讚
因為我發現很多存股族很兇
就是你挑戰他的信仰他就不爽
因為他已經存一輩子了
他不想被你挑戰
我没有挑战信仰
我只是强调说
0050这个东西的好处是
因为我不是重压一个公司
所以任何里面的一家公司倒掉
就是换下一个补商
可是赵丰金
当然我相信很多人讲的
大到不能倒
可能吧
但是我们过去台湾有多少
所谓的大到不能倒的公司
最后面倒掉了
你回去找看看太多了
银行也有
那集团也有
立霸什么的
就是所谓的大到不能倒的东西
那是一个传说
就是你说苹果
会不会可能在五年后倒掉
我不会告诉你说不可能
但是你说
VO会不会在五年后倒掉
不会
因为苹果下去
就换别人去补四肢王而已
所以指数投资的好处就是说
你比较不会踩到雷
当然如果你说
因为指数投资
毕竟是50家公司平均
我干嘛要50家公司平均
我就知道买台湾最屌的公司
我就持有他
OK但前提是你压得到台湾最屌的公司
那大力光之前大家说很屌
就大力光这一两年基本上就跌烂
所以以这个指数投资的角度来看
大力光就会慢慢被剔除掉
可是你就想如果当时是
在两年前开始存大力光的
到现在他就是刹赛
他覺得大力光大到不能倒
這麼強全世界盡頭的領先領導者
當然你說科技股危險金融股OK
那一樣你去找看看
這個我就不一一舉例了
金融股過去說大到不能倒的話
還倒了幾個
所以我還是給大家建議
就假設你真的要存股
雖然我一直強調存股這個觀念不是太好
因為存會給你一個暗示
好像是定存很安全
沒有就是股票市場真的沒有什麼東西是安全的
真的到現在我覺得很好的標的
我都不覺得它是100%安全的
所以不要有這個存的觀念
但是如果你真的要存的話
那因為直速型ETF它的好處就是
它會把不好的鈦調好的拉進來
所以至少它會有這個活水更新的過程
那比你單壓一隻標的
就假設它出事情它就沒有
那個差很多的
然後再來就是我們剛剛單純的看報酬率
就是贏了三倍
那如果說你把這個股息再投入
一個是配4%
一個平均配4%
一個平均配6%再投入
那一樣0050還是贏
所以不是要去比說哪個比較強
反正基本上你要存這個也可以
只是很多人在問這個問題
它會鬼打強一點
就是他会一直觉得说
这个东西在涨
就等于说我没有钱在投入
不是啊
你重点是要干总报酬率啊
兄弟
不是说什么你有拿到配息
然后你就是
就没有问题了
就像你说0050一直往上涨
那我如果要花费
赵峰金至少会配息给我花
0050不会配息给我花
那你就卖掉一点点啊
你卖掉一点点
不就是一样可以当生活费吗
那个概念是完全一样的
然后你说他不会配息
也没有
他也是会配息给你
所以你这里面有蛮多的问题
我希望你可以好好再想一下
你应该就会厘清了
但是如果你坚持要存赵凤金
其实真的没有太多问题
因为真的在投资里面
就是折击所爱爱击所折
搞不好赵凤金在未来五年
屌打零零零零
也是有可能的
所以我们都不会把话说死
反正只是我给你那个建议说
假设你硬要存
还是存直数型ETF的用意
是因为至少他爆掉的机会
比单一公司爆掉的机会
来的低太多
然后重点是他的报酬也很不错
所以大家是这样
那这期节目先聊到这边
就这样 拜